assalamualaikum greetings a piece
someone talking about grounding or
earthing sajda and just being grateful
and thankful for us having this in our
deen now I want to start off with
grounding or what's called earthing the
concept is that when we're literally in
touch with the earth we absorb electrons
that help neutralize the free radicals
in our body that damage our cells
birthings proponents say this grounding
can reduce inflammation pain and stress
if you're grounded
your blood is flowing as long as you
stay grounded and it also thins the
blood so you're less likely to have a
heart attack and stroke in fact the
thins the blood so much that if you're
taking a blood thinner you have to lower
the dose that's the power of grounding
the grounding is so critical for your
brain it causes instantaneous changes in
your left feet of left brain - right
it's where the right brain what's going
on there that's the creative side the
left brain that's analytical side as
soon as you ground yourself your left
brain goes to powers down right brain
doesn't change but your left brain does
is it helps to enhance circulation so
with increased circulation now you have
more energy you have more nutrients
you're carrying away more wastes so that
has a tremendous positive effect on the
body improved sleep is another major
benefit according to the earthing
research nowadays they're finding out
that connecting your body to the earth
many people are doing this now by
walking look look just barefoot just
connecting your your body to the earth
releases these electrostatic charges
that develop in the body and this can
also cause headaches neck aches muscle
spasms and new reach research is showing
that a lot of good science to point out
people who ground sleep better have
lower inflammation and feel better
throughout the day have a better mood
just by grounding or earthing you can
release these electro
static charges is amazing because we do
this five times a day in select yeah
alladhina amanu cows judo boudoir Bankim
boudoir Abeka masala yai lancome to flee
food we take our forehead and we ground
ourselves we ground ourselves in sajda
insula and we know that the problem
ahamed lasts in front of us in peace and
blessings be upon him he told us that
the closest a person is to his creator
is in prostration now there are so many
spiritual benefits he tells us in one
hadith and even magic that through the
Salah through the prayer one cures many
illnesses and we usually often think of
the spiritual this is the biggest
illness that most people are that we get
affected by the top senate ease the
carcinogens through the air pollution
through the food that we eat but often
people neglect the spiritual toxic
elements that affect our heart and we
know that the problem Ahamed peace and
blessings be upon him told us that there
is a flesh a piece of flesh in the body
if it is sound the whole body is sound
if it's corrupted if it's dead the whole
body will be dead that's the heart and
that spiritual aspect of it is the most
important that the benefits are
tremendous from the salat but now when
people when we start finding out that
also the physical elements that anything
that the creator's told us to do in this
Deen is beautiful it's such a blessing
that many people we don't do it for the
physical benefits we do it for those
spiritual blessings of gaining nearness
many people have this false notion that
why does God need our prayer he doesn't
need our prayer if the whole of mankind
were to come to worship Him
benefit his Dominion or if everyone
protested and didn't want to pray or
didn't want to worship it wouldn't
affect his kingdom at all it's for us we
need the salat we gain closeness
god-consciousness taqwa through the
salat so many benefits as the crater
Allah tells us in the Quran that truly
through the remembrance of Allah do
hearts find tranquility Sakina rest you
know people often have this anxiety you
have anxiety attacks and they can't even
get rid of this stuff they they overdose
on xanax and all sorts of other
antidepressants and the heart I remember
before I started to implement this Deen
this way of life into my life that there
was always this this anxiety the stress
the heart was never calm and finally
through Sadat the heart became calm and
Hum did it not so that's the spiritual
blessing of it and it helps you to
through having taqwa you connect with
your Creator and your more consciousness
of him you're going to be a better human
being all around now that's one aspect
but I'm focusing more now on because we
think it's just spiritual but also the
physical aspect to the prostration
through the sedge de through the raku
through these movements that we do we're
also discovering these movements once
you stop moving you're on your way to
death movement is so important for life
movement and we get those movements also
in the set of every movement that we do
it helps the spine it helps the body
it stretches us it helps us there's so
many benefit and now I'm sharing with
you the grounding as they call it
earthing and connecting that to the
sedge de we have that already while
they're making these modern discoveries
the benefits of it be thankful and I'll
close with that have sugar have as a be
thankful said hum did it not that we
have this in the deen and if you want to
go ahead and benefit also from this from
being maybe in a park and your
back yard you know making such the in a
clean environment maybe just taking your
shoes off and connecting with the earth
connecting with your Creator who created
the earth and walking barefoot and there
are no harms there only benefits and I'm
going to post something along with this
video on our Facebook page and on our
YouTube page you can read the some of
the articles one in particular that I
have up that talks about this I hummed
it a lot this is amazing I thought I'll
also share this with you until next time
subscribe if you haven't already assalam
alaikum peace be with you increased
blood flow to the face drains the
sinuses decreasing the chance of
inflammation of that area
prostration also reduces the possibility
of developing hernia or hemorrhoids
moreover prostration allows for the one
third of air retained in the lungs to
escape which the body is unable to
exhale while standing upright or in any
other position in the unique position of
prostration the back and neck muscles
are exercised and therefore both areas
are strengthened it is done 34 times a
day hence it's amazing physical benefits
bowing prostrating and getting up all
activate numerous muscles in the body
increasing physical well-being even the
final sitting position has a soothing
and calming effect both on body and mind
glory be to Allah the creator of all
that exists I will be laying in a shape
on your lodging
mmm bismillahir off man you're walking
al hamdulillah humble I am
a Walkman you're walking
manikyam we do
hmm eeeh cannot win you're gonna stop
mm then I swear off a little stepping
mmm so it often Lavina and I'm telling
you I did enough boobie island wallah
bismillah my man you were laugh-in in
salafi who's 11 a man who is ollie
hearty whatever so be healthy whatever
so miserable
allahu akbar subhan Arabella deem
subhana rabbi al azim subhana rubella
deem semi allahu liman hamidah our
abouna lakal hamd allahu akbar
subhana rabbi l-alamin RPL Allah subhana
rabbi Allah Allah
Allahu Akbar el phileo la awfully Allah
Allah Walker
subhana rabbi l Allah subhana rabbi
Allah subhana rabbi Allah Allah Allah
Walker